well Olivia Wilde isn't done speaking
out after her ex-nanny claimed she
cheated on Jason Sudeikis with Harry
Styles we aren't so easily manipulated
a Carefree looking Olivia stepping out
to the gym in La is fully aware of all
the gossip in fact she posted a salad
dressing recipe hours after claim
surface that Jason once laid down under
her car to stop her from bringing Harry
a homemade salad with her special
dressing oh and Olivia seems to be
sending hidden messages the recipe is a
page ripped from Nora Efron's book
Heartburn about a woman in a failed
marriage who plans to leave her
oblivious hubby the first thing you want
to do is make the kind of dressing so
you're going to chop some garlic and
look what we found Olivia actually
brought her recipe to the Food Network
in 2020 less than six months before the
split news broke and you have it with
your salad
this is sort of the end result
the ex nanny is doubling down on her
claims telling thedailymail.com that
while seeing Harry Olivia continued
visiting Jason sleeping over and sent
her now estranged ex-loving messages
that all stopped when Olivia was
photographed holding hands with Harry
early last year other claims that Olivia
gave the family dog Gordon away so she
could spend more time with the singer
and a couple's therapist told Jason
quote Harry is her crack this is like an
addiction she has
there's been no further comment from
either Jason or Olivia the two told E.T
these are false and scurrilous
accusations but check out what Kelly
Ripa is saying in response to the star
who slammed her Kathy Lee Gifford I
don't get it I don't get it I'm not
going to read the book I haven't read it
I am not going to entertain
criticism from people who didn't read
the book appearing on the not skinny but
not fat podcast Kelly explains that
Kathie Lee's comments about her Memoir
Livewire which details some drama about
her time as reached Philbin's co-host
helped sales and suddenly there's all of
this attention on my book it's like
thank you because I think that people
that read the book will have a very
different uh take on the book
[Music]